une phobie de l'avion je n'ai jamais
pris de ma vie vraiment toi tu voudrais
donner la place à qui n'a d'yeux mathieu
domaine que je sais que tout a été édité
au nom de daniel mo ti matthieu
delormeau nous regardent faut qu'il
vienne à l'aéroport habillé comme daniel
alors acte 5 actes finale matthieu
delormeau l'at-il fait ou pas match nul
à toulouse matthieu delormeau l'at-il
fait ou pas est bien est ce que vous
voulez qu'on démarre tout de suite par
l'arrivée à l'aéroport en laponie
voilà on a tous ont été tous invités à
se rendre à l'aéroport c'est l'aéroport
charles de gaulle
non bien sûr du porte-avions et est-ce
que matthieu delormeau est arrivé en
agnel moreau mathieu c'est parti pour
garder c'est le premier acte vers la
laponie
[Musique]
il avait commencé fouad el himma
et un seigneur mais c'est pas si tôt
qu'annoncé en baisse et aux biens soient
perturbées par ketty
[Musique]
sa ville de thann à l'automne je vais
t'appeler svetlana ouais tu vas pas
aller voter avec un match aller à modène
mali mon frère s'est embourgeoisé elles
sont bons journaux et occupa non ans
qu'ils font équipe accueillera la coupe
était bouche
[Musique]
il en a partout
les frères jeannet de la course et amène
les gens à capendu par les 6 sur 10
alice une petite assistante de prod
complètement ma came
je me dis que ça part sur les bonnes
actions et un jeu peut-être pas mon nuit
en fête et ou de leurs bourses et de
leurs mots qui m'inquiète c'est sûr
ouais
[Applaudissements]
cela
ça va prendre un épicier voisine était
rue bayard excusez-moi moreau daniel je
veux gagner mon ticket pour la laponie
la laponie sait où la laponie sipa
à daniel savamment benjamin qui je vois
arriver à l'aéroport de leurs mots en
dan et de lanvaux voilà évidemment il
dit prêt à tout pour contrer avec nous
mêmes au ridicule et rebond ça tue pas
sinon il serait mort depuis très
longtemps
daniel moreau daniel daniel moreau
daniel j'ai gagné mon billet pour l'un à
pogny joue est en business regarder un
business bleu bleu ciel de provence
blanc blanc blanc le goéland le goéland
les aînés daniel oui tu sais quoi
j'ai honte parce que la poche est
heureux que la fois je pense à ce de
leurs mots qui restait mais avait pour
lui daniel tobos dis donc
mais si comme moi que moi je suis de
phase aller et là le rêve arrive de
leurs maux le vrai tu es toi qui tire il
doit y avoir une erreur je suis en écho
c'est vrai
c'est chelou faire non excuse moi vous
êtes qui de leurs mots je prends des
coups non mais tu ne sais pas moi c'est
pas moi qui ai payé du poteau que moi je
suis moi j'en ai moi aussi mon sac
revers raté contre moi mais je pense que
je penche sur les compteurs mais
naturellement je prends deux tiers des
comores je suis parce que j'en ai un
mais ça devrait bien mal pense que je
suis en écho battant m mathieu quoi
s'est excusé moi voilà excusez moi
madame la business c'est là bas c'est
vraiment un matin
[Musique]
merci attendait un truc intéressant de
maxime il est 10 heures 10 heures sont
les heures miroir gangs au salvador
demain nous aurons 12h12 moi c'est marie
tout le temps tu ne t'en as pas d un
miroir et une affaire avec tous les sens
la mule plusieurs fois par jour celle-ci
forme de quoi tomber ça c'est leur
miroir alors ce biais la dualité sam ont
été connectés sur le bon chemin
[Musique]
maxime source tués
les airs miroir plaisir à voir
on se reparle à mesure nous j'étais
vraiment surpris j'ai monté au filet ce
match peut pas avoir assez attention la
roja bakero ginon jaloux
alors roger roger c'est comme si tu
avais des dalles attentions pressantes
auxquelles on trouve des fines c'est sûr
que là c'est pour moi c'est une affaire
parce qu'on est bouclée mais si delphine
ça cafouille est journaliste on n'est
jamais tout s'écroule en slip donc ses
oeufs dans le même panier choix comment
dire laponie donc là je suis à fond
[Musique]
suivant le thème ils doivent plus élevé
castagna cotation à revoir
[Musique]
vous connaissez série mais il adore
comme ça qu'on se construit comme basten
là je laisse gagner
normal c'est le patron et encore je suis
là 2% j'ai pas tout donné voilà pu le
battre là après c'est allé battre et je
me vengerai
[Musique]
et à daniel moreau hymne écrit ce solo
de mathieu il est plus beau et plus
élégant que moi c'est pas vrai mais tout
aussi belle daniel narcisse ici c'est
beaucoup plus bêtes